i got a bad feeling about this  what is this place  castle vader the galaxy's first  all-inclusive luxury theme resort  [Music]  within these walls lies tails almost too  terrifying to tell would you like to  hear them  why is that lightning inside  oh that's a big one  the legendary tales of the sith speak of  the thirst for power oh no join us then  and take what you want  this isn't funny the devotion of the  undead rise  and submit it for your approval a tale  of desire i wish i was a pilot join the  imperial academy i will train you oh  yeah  is that really what happened no it's not  be afraid be very afraid  [Music]  so  what do you think  a little on the news is what i think  everyone gets scared kid  without fear you can't have courage  ears b1496113  [Music]  you